Having defined the variables,
we're now ready to move on to
building the boolean formula.
We're going to start with
the clauses needed so
that given a satisfying assignment,
it's clear how to fill out the table.
Nevermind for
now about whether the corresponding
sequence has valid transitions.
For now, we just want the individual
configurations to be well-defined.
First, we have to enforce that at each
step, the machine is in some state.
Hence, for all steps i,
at least one of the state variables for
that step has to be true.
Note that r denotes
the number of states here.
In this context, it's just a constant.
The input to our reduction is just
the string that we need to transform
into a boolean formula.
The machine also can't be
in two states at once.
So we need to enforce that constraint
as well by saying that for every pair
of state variables for a given turn
step, one of the two has to be false.
Together, these sets of clauses
enforce that the machine corresponding
to a satisfying tooth assignment.
Is in exactly one state after each step.
For the position of the head,
we have a similar set of clauses.
The head has to be over some
square on the tape, but
it can't be in two places at once.
And lastly, each square on the tape
has to have exactly one symbol.
Thus, for all steps I and squares J,
there has to be some symbol on
the square, but there can't be two.
The other clauses related to individual
configurations come from the start and
end states.
The machine must be in the initial
configuration at step zero.
This means that the initial state must
be q0, that the head be over the first
position on the tape, and that the first
part of the tape contained input w.
The rest of the tape must
be set to blank to start.
And finally, the computation
must end in an accepting state.
This we can enforce
with the single clause
that the state after step
p(n) be the accepting state.